quand l'hôpital d'orléans des ménages
toute la ville est au courant
en ce jour de juin c'est la maternité
qui quitte ses anciens locaux situés en
centre ville pour s'installer 10
kilomètres plus loin
du matin au soir les ambulances des
films sous protection policière pour ne
pas perdre une minute
le plus délicat est de déplacer certains
grands prématurés ou des bébés comme la
petite les ânes qui vient tout juste de
naître dans des conditions difficiles et
qui nécessitent une attention permanente
les branches est responsable mais lui
les branches qui risquent de tomber pile
poil au moment qu'il fallait pas de
brevet bon ça va aller quand même
c'est une chance de stracel en plus ah
oui oui oui ça c'est sûr déjà
l'accouchement c'était compliqué tout ça
va des choses pour respirer tout ça a un
peu de mal et là va être emmené en pire
c'est une épreuve de plus
les enfants qu'on a transféré ce matin
c'est lé plus les plus fragiles les
enfants grands prématurés les enfants
qui font moins de milgram des enfants
qui ont un support ventilatoire dont ces
enfants là effectivement sont en
réanimation néonatale et puis au fur et
à mesure de la journée on a transféré
les enfants qui avaient besoin de moins
de de soins lourds ou des enfants qui
était proche du terme qui ont une
pathologie qui nécessite quelques jours
de d'hospitalisation pas comme les
grands prématurés qui sont hospitalisés
pendant des semaines voire des mois
enfin chez les grands prématurés un
transfert peut effectivement il avait
déstabilisé donc il faut apporter les
conditions optimales de transfert
prendre le rôle le temps de s'assurer
qu'ils sont stabilisés et après
seulement de donner le top départ pour
le transfert le plus compliqué c'est les
problèmes en fait d'ordre technique par
exemple un problème notamment
d'ascenseur un problème
d'incubateur de batterie un problème de
respirateurs ça c'est la partie
complètement technique et puis surtout
c'est la dégradation d'un nouveau-né ça
c'est notre stress permanent
on a fait deux répétitions pour savoir
justement le temps qu'on mettrait quel
était le meilleur trajet dont on aurait
besoin de quel dispositif de sécurité
l'équipement médical optimal
aux etats unis
quarante deux nouveau nés ont ainsi été
transférés en une journée une opération
préparée pendant plus de six mois en
étudiant la façon dont avaient pratiqué
d'autres hôpitaux qui ont connu un
déménagement comme celui de port royal à
paris
en moins d'une heure les ânes a été
transféré vers sa nouvelle chambre dont
elle va être la toute première au cul
porte maintenant ses déboires
individuels alors croire on avait des
chambres communes
donc ne serait ce que pour le secret
professionnel pour la confidentialité
par rapport aux enfants et pour les
parents du coup ça va être beaucoup plus
pratique
d'autant plus qu'on a beaucoup plus de
place dans les chambres pour pouvoir
s'occuper des enfants fait savait
beaucoup plus fonctionnel pour nous est
beaucoup plus sympa pour les parents du
coup
le côté
c'est pour
des chambres plus grande et des couloirs
beaucoup plus long le matériel médical
des ménages prend même temps que les
bébés en ce jour d'installation tout le
monde cherche encore ses repères
oui c'est vrai qu'il me suit des micros
qui lui demande
combien de ce livre reste à déménager 2
2 avec des dames encore un travail où
ils sont embauchés dans deux heures au
quai bompas super maxi à oui ce sera
tous aujourd'hui une qui est emballé
maintenant est une qui le sera dans deux
heures parce qu'il ya encore une
patiente dans la salle de l'ancienne
maternité devait fermer définitivement
ses portes à 8h ce matin là mais il ya
le règlement il y a les lois de la
nature
quelques bébés ont décidé de prendre
leur temps
le service assure les derniers
accouchement dans des locaux où le
personnel a voulu laisser l'empreinte de
son passage avant de s'en aller dans les
salles de travail et dans la salle de
repos
c'est un jour pas comme les autres
laura les gamins qu'on aura vu naître
ici qui vont être fac là pour les
épinettes retard contre le temps que ça
se construit
oui car quand même une vingtaine
d'années j'ai fait déjà le premier
déménagement de l'ancienne maternité a
ici et là je repars maintenant et puis
après ça sera la fin de ma carrière
donc ça fait on va pas compter les
années ça fait trop c'est difficile de
partir
non c'est pas difficile de partir parce
que tu es une pour moi pas trop mais
c'est une nouvelle aventure
sur le parking les ambulances côtoient
les camions de déménagement les maires
qui ont accouché quelques heures plus
tôt sont rapidement transféré vers le
nouveau site avec le matériel nécessaire
pour les accueillir
blouse blanche d'un côté tee-shirts
noirs de l'autre et chacun ses méthodes
oh oui il part donc c'est le moment que
quelques copains avec un accord
l'ambiance est plus courant oui tout à
fait et qui sert de salle de naissance
d'accord bas tout le monde l'a bien fait
trembler tous genres est reparti
à la nouvelle maternité les équipes se
préparent aussi à accueillir la première
naissance
deux mamans qui ont commencé le travail
dans la nuit sont en concurrence pour
l'inauguration
c'est finalement la petite lina qui
arrive la première elle devient le
premier bébé né dont le nouvel hôpital
d'orléans la source
on avait dit tout ça cette nuit et on a
atterri à la madeleine à 4 heures du
matin une première contraction régulière
et sauf que le col s'ouvrait pas donc
ils nous ont rapatrié ici on arrivait à
quelle heure 9h 9h30 10h et puis voilà
et puis ça a commencé tout doucement et
plus ça allait plus les contractions
accéléré voilà mais ça c'est fini un
césarienne en même temps vos côtés des
choses si vous faites inauguration de la
maternité de l'âge on affine et la
madeleine ont été les derniers à partir
on est parti dans les cartons et on
arrivait ici
voilà ça serait une belle anecdote à
dire à raconter mais jusque quand on
sera plus
doug est
la choix du poumon a été bien entouré
aussi oui
bon
l'hôpital d'orléans à la joie de vous
faire part de la naissance de sa
nouvelle maternité sa gestation aura
duré dix ans mais ses géniteurs sont
pour l'instant très fier du résultat
avant à l'hôpital madeleine notre ancien
hôpital les chambres étaient des
chambres doubles souvent pas de
sanitaires dans les chambres les femmes
étaient obligés d'aller prendre leur
douche dans le couloir dans les salles
de bains là toutes les chambres
pratiquement sont des chambres seules
avec salle de bain à incorporer donc
c'est vraiment un confort supplémentaire
pour les femmes pour le personnel c'est
des locaux qui sont plus vastes plus
adapté parce qu'en fait l'hôpital
madeleine historiquement était conçu
pour sûrement beaucoup moins
d'accouchement on à la maternité est
passé à doubler son nombre
d'accouchements en une dizaine d'années
donc forcément les locaux étaient un peu
étroit donc on gagne aussi un confort
pour le personnel je pense des
organisations qui ont été repensés pour
sauver l'hôpital avec au niveau de la
maternité bain une salle nature qui a
été mise en place
l'idée étant que les femmes puissent
accoucher le plus naturellement possible
mais dans un compte dans un endroit sûr
avec tout ce qu'on peut leur proposer la
technique autour si jamais les choses
tournent au moins bien que l'on imagine
ici on trouvera donc un espace réservé
aux méthodes naturelles dans un
environnement global où les machines
joue un rôle de plus en plus grands
dans les sous sols comme dans les étages
les robots assiste ou remplace l'homme
pour certaines tâches
bienvenue dans l'hôpital du 21e siècle
quant à l'hôpital du 20e siècle son
avenir est encore incertain
dans quelques années le site de la porte
madeleine pourrait accueillir une partie
de l'université
en attendant sa transformation le lieu
conserve la mémoire de ce qui s'y est
passé ici
des dizaines de milliers d'hommes et de
femmes sont nés